Speaker 1: We've talked before about how the
Post Trump Dr. Anthony Fauci is sort of a
new Dr. Fauci who both feels that the pandemic
is being managed more competently and feels
that he can simply stick to medical advice
without having to kind of calculate what he
says from the standpoint of whether the administration
will like it or won't they like it.
That's a different Dr. Fauci than we saw during
the Trump administration.
And Dr. Fauci was interviewed yesterday on
CNN and went right at one of the most notable.
It's not even really a hypocrisy.
It's really a contradiction by the American
right wing on the pandemic.
They want everything to be over, but they
refused to do the things that will accelerate
the end of the pandemic.
They want to go back to normal, but they couldn't
even avoid bars and big parties for a few
months in 2020.
And of course, they're saying open everything
now.
It's time to end everything from a social
perspective.
But now they don't want to get vaccinated.
I told you last week, 43 percent of Republicans
say they don't want the vaccine and they don't
plan to get it unless for some reason they
have no choice.
So Dr. Fauci was asked about it yesterday
on CNN.
He calls it like it is.
He explains that the people who most claim
to want everything to be over are actually
making it go longer by their opposition to
the vaccine and their other actions.
Take a look at our new poll.
Speaker 2: This week shows that 43 percent
of Republicans still don't want to get the
vaccine.
How frustrating is this for you, Dr. Fauci?
You know, Dana, it is quite frustrating because
the fact that one may not want to get vaccinated
in this case, a disturbingly large proportion
of Republicans only actually works against
where they want to be.
They want to be able to say these restrictions
that are put on by public health recommendations
are things that they're very concerned about.
We're all concerned about that.
We share that concern.
But the way you get rid of those restrictions
is to get as many people vaccinated as quickly
and as expeditiously as possible, because
when that happens for absolutely certain,
you're going to see the level of virus in
the community go down and down and down to
the point where you would not have to have
those public health restrictions.
So it's almost paradoxical that on the one
hand, they want to be relieved of the restrictions,
but on the other hand, they don't want to
get vaccinated.
It just almost doesn't make any sense.
Speaker 1: Paradoxical is exactly the right
word to apply to this situation.
Now, it's also hopeless for Dr. Fauci to expect
these very people to go and get the vaccine.
Dr. Fauci wants the people who are against
abortion but don't want easier access to.
Contraception to realize that they could end
the pandemic sooner if they got vaccinated
and this exists a ton on the right, we are
against abortion no matter what.
OK, great.
Well, let's reduce demand for abortions.
To do that, we prevent unwanted pregnancy.
Well, what prevents unwanted pregnancy?
Access to contraception, comprehensive sex
ed?
Oh, but they're also against that.
What?
It's the exact same thing Dr. Fauci said.
It almost doesn't make any sense.
I would remove the word almost.
It just doesn't make any sense and very little.
We're going to talk later about this.
Actually, very little of the modern Republican
Party makes any sense.
It's not just their position on ending the
pandemic.
If you want to talk about other things that
make no sense, consider the big picture on
vaccines from these people.
The virus isn't serious.
It's just like the flu.
So everything can stay open.
But Trump is developing a vaccine which he
deserves credit for, which they're not going
to take anyway.
But he'd better get the credit for it, even
though we don't need it and they won't take
it.
And the pandemic is not serious anyway.
Well, then hold on a second then.
Why is it that Trump's a hero for developing
the vaccine you won't take and don't need?
And by the way, what is pro-life about their
positions on any of these things?
They don't want to get the vaccine nor wear
a mask, but they want to end the pandemic.
Our patience for this nonsense should be very,
very low.
And I've said this before, and that's maybe
a good point to end gun rights come with responsibilities.
I have an entire YouTube segment about this
that you can find to just go around demanding
rights.
Absent and completely ignoring the responsibilities
that come with them is not a recipe for a
well functioning society.
And unfortunately, we're going to have to
go around them or through them in order to
fix this situation.
They're not going to work with us.
And that's maybe the worst part of all of
it, because people who are doing the right
things are still going to suffer.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is
a viewer and listener supported program, you
can support it by grabbing a membership at
Join Pakman dot com.